what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
Wednesday episode 4. today John how are
you I am groovy and ready to get spooky
how are you I I like that you know what
else I like I like when you guys hit the
like button please hit that like button
it does wonders around here so please go
ahead and do that also subscribe and
click that notification Bell to get
notified when our reaction is up for the
next episode of Wednesday and uh full
length Direction watch along as we sync
with your own copy of Wednesday
available for super sexy rejects on our
patreon page over there we cover several
shows exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
thank you so much to everyone who has
followed us on our patreon your support
means the globe we're overtaking it all
right guys let's do it
foreign
gag
Dr kinbot tells me I should get out more
it's so cool yeah
what remains of the chest and torso
indicates a frenzied attack subject has
been almost entirely disemboweled
yikes subjects left foot is missing
it appears to have been chewed off at
the ankle Beast has a necklace made of
feet appreciate you coming back to the
office Doug no problem Sheriff I thought
you should see this before I issued my
report on the latest victim it's a real
noodle scratcher
the Killer cut off two toes from the
victim's left foot gross it's like a
reverse nesting doll at least I'm going
out in style Friday is my last day
happy retirement duck I couldn't
surprise Mrs Anwar with a four-week
cruise
hmm
excited to trade rip shields for my ties
let him go talk he's your only friend I
get it
[Music]
full rigor you've been dead a while I
guess you won't mind waiting another day
for me to cut you open oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but also oh [ __ ] I think again
luckily great hiding spot
five more minutes
I was just getting comfortable
[Laughter]
dude I bet you have all kinds of sensory
deprivation experiences in one of those
[Music]
whoa what a nut whoa
turns out all of the monsters victims
have had body parts surgically removed
the first one a kidney the second one a
finger Wednesday I don't really feel
like the third one gallbladder
murders aren't mindless he's collecting
trophies like a seasoned serial killer
it's quite impressive actually
reaction
s got your smelling salts
again
be happy you got color on your side of
the room now tweak to my back fencer the
Orchid produces a pheromone that mimics
a female insect once the plant is
pollinated what do the male insects get
in exchange not a just like all the guys
at the Raven oh
Burns achieving a DJ haven't seen blood
suckers how about needles in my eyes
could probably do that anyway
or you could invite someone and have a
little fun yeah
follow the clues to the dance
this is home see if you didn't get those
scratches from fencing
he's hiding something
he's hiding a mislead
yeah he's hiding Tyler
[Music]
well I'm staying steady on my theory yep
still Tyler it's changes nothing
you just became that much more
interesting yeah but if he was bringing
the life out of the drawings they
wouldn't be that sturdy right I
am not wavering Wednesday
Xavier
what are you doing nothing
why don't you give me a tour
maybe another time why were you looking
for me
advice is a dance and to say yes
it's just about a certain dance that
makes you want to poke needles into your
eyes perhaps
I'm all ears this was my chance to get
up close and personal with a potential
series
how could I refuse are you really going
to make me ask
would you
would you go to the dance with me
and then projectile vomits I thought
you'd never ask
neither did I
oh my god let's say Adams is going to
the Raven you need something that
screams first days stand back [ __ ] I
have arrived and I know just the place
oh where are we going
yeah our first roomy shopping spree the
dance committee's suggesting all white
to match the theme but that's not gonna
fly with us I just love the spirit of
the show yeah I'm going to seek helping
I'm not stop
damn damn yeah get that one that is the
one are you going to the Raven this
weekend
I'm not required to answer your
questions out in the wild am I
could bump into my therapist and say
that
[Laughter]
I don't require answer questions out in
the wild Emma I've followed you around
all week just to be able to say that
person who drew this at your suspect
you bring me some concrete evidence
maybe we'll talk
get some concrete concrete evidence are
you looking for I'm gonna cast one of
those freaking big creature here
so why are you sitting here Lucas Walker
I got a friend who works at hot Couture
she overheard you on the hunt for a date
to The Raven maybe we can help each
other out
what's your game mayor boy
you guys the Raven coming up this
weekend right I must be the only one
we're going
it's an act of self-preservation
sure that happens I guess so who is it
savior
oh no oh hope you two have fun I'm not
sure why you're becoming upset call me
crazy Wednesday but you keep giving me
these signals it's not my fault I can't
interpret your emotional Morse code
that's a line that's a bar am I in the
more than friend zone or just a pawn in
some game you're playing I feel you man
Story of My Life bro I need to
prioritize
thanks for clearing that up
just give me a call if I ever move up
your to-do list
ouch how is he becoming more of the edgy
badass
Wednesday you're a heartbreaker
could you get the shoe roomie putting a
good word for me I hear she still saw
his date for The Raven oh golly people
like me and you were different we're
original thinkers Intrepid outliers in
this vast Cesspool of adolescents
disrupters you're not going to the Raven
either
actually I am
with Xavier
I see oh poor Eugene Circle
I think I know where that is show me
oh yeah that's a very
it's a very Tim burtony hole versus
just a king chamber
yeah it's just someone's dungeon
yachty
Yahtzee what is that
concrete proof that's a bingo
[Music]
God damn it
I came here to seduce you how do you
know what the Monster looks like
were these all just self-portraits oh
what you think it's me I saved your life
so did the monster you are so out of
line right now I'm just trying to
uncover the truth and your art seems to
have a recurring Motif
this creature's been haunting my dreams
for the past couple weeks I try to block
it out but I can't so I just
come in here and paint it when I was
painting this one the claws reached out
of the canvas and took a swipe at me wow
damn
you were in here
before when I caught you outside
that's the only reason you asked me to
the Raven isn't it I mean you'll still
go right yeah I mean we're still on
you are unbelievable it's nothing
personal no it never is with you is it
I mean do you even care about anyone or
anything at all Wednesday
yeah thing truly the tortured artist
definitely Tyler yeah
that's the claw of the monster and
that's a dried blood sample from a
potential suspect when the DNA test and
see if they match I'm not playing games
Adams neither am I Sheriff
clearly
she's done more for this investigation
than anyone on your team you know I
figured since neither you nor I have a
date to the dance we should go together
right no oh so we stuck out the cave and
identify the monster it's better than a
dance you should have gotten you
cheating
so
I hear you might be free tomorrow night
after all
you don't have a date already I think
she was waiting for him
[Music]
just the tips what are you did you get
permission from Wednesday to do this
laughs
[Music]
a little Matchmaker thing
[Music]
damn this is where vecna fought 11. yep
someone dropped running up that hill
right now you were never more Student
Life don't you remember being full of
Hope and excitement about the Raven all
our members disappointment
the boy I asked turn me down for another
girl Gomez go there that's he murdered
her heart
I'm coming Eugene
Eugene oh no what have you done
Tyler got your invite
guessing you a thing drop it in the tip
jar
good guess
your note was so genuine and oh no
Jesus Christ no
now that I'm here
I'm glad I came no
say yes how would you do this to me
did he steal it
somehow what did you pay for it
five finger discount yeah
[Music]
that's so great let's see this reveal
shot come on
I want to look that good in anything you
look
unrecognizable ridiculous a classic
example of female objectification for
the male gays
amazing I mean it wins that you look
beautiful give us a little smile girl
you'd be a lot prettier
uh what happened to staking up the cave
oh [ __ ]
don't have this discussion in front of
Tyler he's the monster guess I'll check
out the woods myself don't go alone
it's too dangerous we go together
tomorrow night understood
oh poor Eugene I'm afraid Eugene's gonna
die or get maimed or something bad I
don't know Palmer never strides away
from danger no no you know oh
who are we
oh my God so sorry let me fix that
[Music]
in it
yeah yeah
is that your date
yes and he's having the best time with
me we are both loving Let's Dance
together don't cry Enid something's not
right does your mood have to do with a
certain pigtail goth girl
she's not here
we are oh contraire I'm sorry I do
really like being here with you so I
appreciate the last minute invitation so
then we're talking about one
you brought her up yeah
break your own rule
[Applause]
[Music]
time to dance dance girly yeah
Heartbreaker
this is Tyler Galvin
uh yeah double cab no foam two pumps of
sugar-free
I'm gonna go get us some drinks
uh you know each other but beyond the
coffee this looks like a fun ass event
Netflix put it on I come in peace that's
a shame I brought my pocket base
yep yep yep I love her so much I'm the
only one in the world who does I just
don't see what you see man you don't
know what he did to me
he killed my hour mom Xavier told me
what you did last year hey you and your
friends assaulted him and destroyed his
mural on Outreach day
people do not [ __ ] foot around issues
in this show
why'd you do it
I could give you million excuses but
the truth is I'm still trying to figure
that out
um I did a terrible thing but I swear
I'm not a terrible person I think
Wednesday would be attractive that kind
of vibe do you think I was going to
judge you over some lousy prank I would
have taken it further yeah
there's a reason I liked you
[Music]
ah Sushi you know the smiles coming is
in her eyes
in the eyes yeah the smiles and just
like the subtle Communications with each
eye emotions so good so alive
oh [ __ ] oh here we go
what is she doing
yes yes
yes
cool
it's like some rubber already issue yeah
look at that classic Wednesday dance
keep it going girl
yes
[Laughter]
so good
oh my God
yes
I like how it's from like a 60s movie
she looks so hot right now
this is so attractive to you
be drawing you all night
do me a favor what take off your amulet
and make me forget about it oh
you broke up with me because you thought
I was manipulating you with my siren
song
now you want me to use it to help you
get over another girl
you weren't supposed to bring her up so
there's gonna be like an extended
sequence Netflix will put that out as
its own little special like Roger's the
musical or something
guys I was thinking that maybe this
isn't such a good idea I don't want my
dad to get any ball back or anything you
know
to get revenge on those freaks for
nuking crack Stones felt yeah don't tell
me you've got soft like Tyler
oh no don't get a don't get arrested
foreign
oh my God wasn't the sheriff was it my
dear Mother always says
fire test gold
suffering test a woman
that's a bar you don't know what it's
like never knowing people's true
feelings what about your amulet
it's not foolproof
it's a mild prophylactic oh I I prefer
them getting along
lucky
do you tell
think of you everyone keeps saying that
but
might not be entirely true honestly I
wish I cared a little more
huh
[Music]
I really don't want anything to happen
to this guy I'm Knight's gonna be okay
oh my God are they gonna kiss they might
[Music]
uh
Terry yep red dye in the
sprinklers Blade
[Laughter]
the only part of that movie I know
I just smiled what could be better
[Music]
[Laughter]
the humanity
yeah you're gonna choke on that
[Music]
YouTube
Save YouTube
Eugene is in the woods
he's in danger like I should wear it
right after yeah everyone's falling on
the floor just
something's up with her
you did this
I can't believe I fell for your crap oh
ouch
I thought you liked me
wolf ow wolf
owl
get away from her Stone
Kid Cudi Jr and his jerk friends she
blew me off
you ever told me why
I was too embarrassed to tell you but I
accidentally looked in the mirror and
kind of stoned myself with my snakes
[Music]
we should probably take it slow right
totally agree established a safe word
yeah like I'm dying
my face
[Music]
Arthur two monsters over here
oh no this is the shot
[Music]
Eugene
oh no
oh no
oh buddy oh my God
is he alive
[Music]
oh it just got personal ugh
I know what's going on okay all right
get ready for it yeah I'm ready for it
the dad is the sheriff and he's also
okay I refuse to let go of Tyler
I think you might be I feel like there
is some at least at very very least yes
that would make the most that would make
a lot of sense because yeah he goes back
to the cave he wipes the evidence I feel
like in the flash in the brief flash I
caught maybe a little bit of his beard
in there yes so yeah I think
the big question is yeah is he also
monster or is he just trying to cover up
for Tyler but yeah
she seems awfully dismissive of concrete
evidence surely does yes and he doesn't
seem to want much help yes yeah I refuse
to let Tyler go nope too many signs no
ah
I just feel like whenever I predict
something and then I drop it
that you should have stuck to you
eventually drop it after some time and
I'm like oh damn it I shouldn't have
dropped stick to it I I support you I am
still with you my guns I'm still
convinced
um that was a great episode that was the
best one of the season so far yeah man
we dance dance with our hands hands
hands above our heads like Jesus said I
thought um all the genres and elements
of this series from you know the high
school show
to the investigative mystery angle
Supernatural qualities I thought this
was the and it was also like wonderfully
paced and it was really fun and it ends
in a way that feels like the
investigation is really personal now
because you know they had a moment with
Eugene and Wednesday at the very
beginning when
she was pretty much identifying with him
and they you know like she she said in
the last episode you remind me of my
brother and then in this episode or like
there's a certain kind of outcast so
they they do she does care for him right
and so now this is something where she
really does give a [ __ ] and all these
things about not caring and everything
I'm like well that's completely out the
window now like she really does care and
I thought this was a just a wonderfully
I thought I did a great job of
intercutting around all the different
plot lines going to Enid and Bianca and
Xavier like all of them I thought were
really really really interesting and I
thought I had a good ramp up until the
very last shot it was really well
executed like I thought this breathed
really well and was the best edited one
sure and then even to have a moment
where Wednesday's dancing which
um I wouldn't it's because that dance is
so it's a very because I I never saw any
of the dance but I did hear like there's
a there's a dance scene and um like I
think everyone did
I feel like I might have seen like an
image of the dress at one point I'm not
sure it was around the time when I
didn't give a [ __ ] about the shows I
just probably came in one with everyone
yeah
um so I didn't bother to commit anything
I saw it that's good Glimpse that's good
but uh yeah the the even like the dance
scene is is so specifically fine-tuned
to her character like you can't just
have her dance regularly or you can't
have it be something
so obnoxious that it feels like a
cartoon like it has to feel within
really breakdown the ghoulish realm of
of Wednesday which I think having her
dance moves be something that feels a
little bit like the I thought of like
the Thriller zombies doing like a 60s
dance yeah yeah the Thriller mixed with
just yeah that 60s era kind of surf Rock
just kind of like we're all kind of
wiggling and just following yeah it's
not a a specific like erudite dance
steps kind of thing yeah I thought it
was I thought it was excellent I I love
this episode I thought this from
beginning to end like it started off
with a really great morgue scene and it
just kept ramping up and it it stayed
and I I thought everything coalesced in
a way that felt uh rewarding so I I
thought this was a really like this was
their easily out of the four this is the
best one so far yeah yeah I agreed it's
it's I think the show is done nicely to
build steadily across each of these four
episodes we've seen thus far and much in
the same way this episode does have just
like a really nice gradual build up to
like a really nice chaotic Crescendo and
and yeah like I had heard
it's funny coming into the show I knew
that it was like the biggest show ever
on Netflix or one of the biggest you
know viewerships but also you know I'd
heard some some differing reviews about
how it was executed and how good or not
it is and how much it leans into like
why a Trope or whatever else not really
in terms of specifics but just in just
overview and so here I've actually been
so pleased and enthralled by how much
I'm kind of invested in every element
that they're going for like I like just
spending time with the kids and thinking
about the previous episode we watched
even having like I'm sure the the
um Nightshade Society or whatever that
is will come back but even that like I'm
almost not mad that's not more of a
thing because this has sort of managed
to while not completely separating
itself from comparisons we were making
earlier to things like a Harry Potter or
whatever else like it does have its own
unique Adams family-esque charm and I
don't feel like I'm watching Riverdale
or something even though you have
certain elements that are certainly akin
to that so like I think it's at least
for my viewership done really nicely to
both draw me in and invest me but also
just have a lot of you know fun and
character and and Nuance in all the
right little places like part of what I
especially liked about this episode and
leading up to this they've demonstrated
is like they're not afraid to set
something up and then have the
discussion instead of making you wait
like I feel like a lesser show would
have made you wait for her to confront
him about the art or uh for uh Enid and
Ajax to talk about you know what
happened with her getting invited to the
dance and all that stuff like I think
they've made a nice display of both like
an intriguing mystery that even though
we're still pretty convinced of like
what the actual outcome is you know I'm
still like in for it and I think even if
like the outcome we have like a pretty
we're committed to who we suspect I'm
still like excited for the mystery to
keep unfolding and for all the different
little elements to keep presenting
themselves because even if it does turn
out to be what we suspect I'm still
thrilled by the Journey of the mystery
so
yeah because I'm not uh
I would say that if like with the whole
thing which I like don't get me wrong
the show sometimes does throw me for a
loop sure of like okay well he did go to
boarding school or some [ __ ] he was gone
military school clearly has some anger
problems yeah it has to exist before
that also goes to serve the creature
months ago experiences yeah uh yeah it's
more like of course I have my doubts uh
but I'm like no you gotta stay instead
of him I gotta commit this time yeah I
gotta stick it through till the end um
so yeah I think that the way they've
handled every character like I'm
invested in in every I like I like
watching everyone yeah when you're
coming away from Wednesday like I really
I really enjoy Enid uh a hell of a lot I
think she's great she's she's such a
wonderful boisterous personality I love
watching her the sheriff is great too
you know as much as he can be a hard ass
I I like I think he has a lot of good
presents and I really enjoyed the scene
with Bianca and um Wednesday actually
she felt human this episode right
instead of more than just that scene
even her interaction with Xavier when it
came to wipe my memory
a lot of times it has I've been waiting
for Bianca to get interesting because it
has just sort of been your queen bee and
your pining over X
um and it hasn't really been that
evolved and this was the time I'm like
oh you feel like a a three-dimensional
character now yes absolutely uh Xavier I
think it's something about that tortured
artist kind of character who can
sometimes semi-rub me the wrong way for
some reason because you see too much of
yourself in them and you don't like what
you see exactly yeah I'm looking in a
mirror mainly just the looks department
is what I'm looking at not so much the
personality but the looks I don't like
seeing a tall good looking white guy
that's right I deal with that privilege
every day
it's really hard
the the
so sometimes it's perform there's just
something about his performance is that
it's the only one I kind of hover in and
out of it's strange because I always
enjoy watching him I'm never like get
off the screen man I always enjoy
watching him but he's the one who wavers
in and out of moments of believability
to me in certain parts of his delivery
the funny thing is you feel about Xavier
the way I feel about time Tyler yeah
because I like Tyler right I actually I
do too I enjoy Tyler a lot but he has to
me he has a and and it's and it's the
range of the performance has grown over
these episodes but especially the first
couple I was like he's got a specific
delivery for most of his lives well I
think they're having him to if it is him
as the monster it would stand a reason
that they put him in a certain kind of
framework with the delivery yeah because
it's supposed to be like when you go
back and watch the season this is all
it's all hinging off of whether or not
then it's one of those you're like oh I
get what he's doing now you know yeah
um but I I he could see has the kid from
they both have a variation of kid of the
wrong side of the tracks kind of
performance yeah
um but him especially is a normie for
now but Eugene that's sad I was really
the second he decided to go on his own I
was like [ __ ]
or like beginning of episode five it's
like oh he's he's okay he's it's not my
blood or something or or hey he'll live
at least I don't know I'm hoping fingers
crossed although like I also I
appreciate that with this show I
wouldn't necessarily put it past them
it's like even though you they had that
bit with Rowan where you technically see
him he died so like he could uh Eugene
could die and I think that's an another
nice thing about this show is even
though there are elements that are fun
and familiar and that you can sort of
sit and poke and predict I think they're
good at tripping the light in certain
moments where you're pulled out of that
and you are just kind of invested or
concerned and this is a show where
actually funny enough like I think the
the love triangle works really well
because I don't I'm like I like them
both I don't know who she'd end up with
you know well it's well Justified yeah
sick I'm kind of sick of love wrinkles
but I think it's well I think the way
they the plot weaves it in and out yeah
as well Justified like I really like how
she asked him to the dance because yeah
it was for the ulterior motives because
it wasn't because she actually
compelled to go with at all like she
doesn't want to go to like and the show
never even alludes that she actually
wants to go whatsoever yeah but I love
of how they've been using thing because
thing is as adorable as that character
isn't as wonderful as the effects design
is uh he's becoming more of this
there's no Uncle Fester in the show yet
but he is becoming like an uncle in a
way of looking out and wanting her to
live have an adolescence a bit yeah yeah
the emotional connection and stuff yeah
I think that's great of how it's how we
manipulated the situation but the that's
what I loved about the writing of it was
because you can see that she's
she was negatively affected by Xavier's
um lashing out towards her over going
into the barn and the drawings and stuff
that she was affected by it especially
when he's like I don't care about anyone
and then to be confronted with the Tyler
situation you know like it it was a nice
push for her to be
tempted slash guilted into going through
with the dance because she couldn't go
through with that emotion again yeah and
I thought it was really well executed so
yeah I think this was uh I thought this
was a absolutely wonderful episode it
had a great pulse about it and it it
never took its foot off the pedal and uh
it had a great it had a lot of fun and
yeah I'm thrown for a loop here
must be two monsters there's gotta be
some other yeah the monster at least has
an accomplice or a helper oh why but I'm
forgetting all about I'm so focused on
the monster that I'm like why was
Gwendolyn Christy though not yeah like
why'd she cover Rowan's death yeah
that's what I can't figure out is it the
mayor God it didn't look like at the
mayor
it's a good well yeah I mean I feel like
there are multiple part of me wonders
like well you know this whip is bad for
Nevermore you know to have a rampaging
creature around especially when
eventually you know you can't pretend
it's a bear forever but uh I don't know
I mean I I have to imagine that with her
there's something yeah more afoot
uh but I'm really curious and I like
that I don't really have like a solid
prediction about that other than just
like I don't fully trust her but even
the way they play her even the way they
play Weems like she is
she's not one note so like even though
she's chewing a lot of scenery a lot of
the time she is a character who does
experience similar things with the other
people and hearing that she like wanted
to go ostensibly to the dance to the
Raven dance with Gomez and stuff back in
the day like they're they're suspicious
things about her but she's also like
enough of a character that yeah I'm
sitting here going I don't know and uh
and I wonder what Miss Thornhill maybe
has to do with it that hasn't been
revealed or what the secret is about her
because she's so in plain sight and
there's got to be something more to her
whole thing she's the most mysterious
character at the moment I feel like
um
I'm just really great I don't know
something you said about the about the
the emotionality of the whole thing
regarding the dance I think it actually
plays really nice to wins again this
show could easily betray its Central
character in a number of ways by needing
to engage us in one way or another but I
think the the way in which you have the
I think the triangle is nice because she
could end up with none of them and it's
sort of like watching her flirt with
connection and emotion and the thing she
says about you know I wish I cared more
like that's a less explored and like a
real thing that I'm sure some people go
through and so like I think they've
found very conscientious ways of of
giving us emotion to connect to with
Wednesday even though the bread and
butter of the character is sort of that
she's not that way
um so yeah there's there's
there's there's like there's more
cleverness at work here than I was
expecting going in I guess she's just
gonna ball her eyes out in the final
scene and then and then yeah just go
straight into like a maniacal laugh
she's gonna be wildly sensitive season
two just cried everything all right guys
well what do you think about this
episode leave your thoughts down below
uh leave a like subscribe you can check
us on patreon thank you so much for
joining us on this journey and uh last
but not least one is for the patreon
got a shout out Michael B omnimedia
Because Omni media uh other than being a
great friend of mine and also the fact
that we uh collaborated on um tales of
the Jedi Coraline we did together too he
has covered Wednesday as well and uh
apparently it's done well for the
Channel people really like his reactions
so if you're looking for more Wednesday
reactions I highly encourage you to go
check out Omni media that's o as in
octopus M as in mother and as in Nancy
one is in the number one it's literally
the number one and then the word media
uh that's a really weird thing to search
up
so Michael thank you so much for being a
great pal and also
um yeah love talking with you all the
time
we do talk a lot all the time I ever
stop talking guys several times a week
can't ever get an edge wise I know I
know John's was left out of the
conversation when we were talking
slowly just
all here across the room he's peering
over my my shoulder with angst and
Jealousy Michael
love you new John
I I am uh you know what it's fine I
deserve that you've been here supporting
us long enough you can be me yeah
oh
that's what we call you call them around
the reject household
old Michael here oh my cool new John
enjoy your name Michael wear it better
than I did I'll do my best to take me
out with Association all right so we're
gonna honor
let's see you guys
[Music]